ils fourbissent leurs armes depuis des
mois en préparation de cet affrontement
légales et politiques
mais alors que le procès en destitution
de donald trump devant le sénat
s'annonce comme un duel entre démocrates
et républicains
les premiers coups sont échangés avant
même son début au sujet des règles
d'engagement les démocrates accusant
leurs rivaux de vouloir précipiter la
procédure pourra quitter le président au
plus vite les règles du procès dit il
semble avoir été écrite par le président
jobs pour le président jobs pour couvrir
ses crimes
rien de tel rétorque le chef des
républicains le procès au sénat sera
équitable dit il contrairement à la mise
en accusation
préparé par la chambre des règles
finalement modifié à la dernière minute
trois jours de plus pour présenter ses
arguments
une concession du chef des républicains
qui ne satisfait cependant par les
démocrates eux réclament le droit de
convoquer des témoins
pourquoi ce procès devrait il être
différent de tout autre procès demande
adam schiff la réponse de l'avocat de la
maison blanche se fait politique
patxi polonais accusent les démocrates
de vouloir empêcher dans notre chambre
de se représenter aux élections
une attaque selon lui contre le droit
sacré des américains de choisir leur
président au rail cette chose sur le
fond des choses
les avocats dans notre chambre ne
prévoit pas contesté les faits qui sont
reprochés au président mais il ne
constitue pas selon eux des crimes
passibles d'une destitution
pour sa part le président lui n'en
démord pas il se dit victime d'une
cabale
tout cela n'est qu'un canular dit il et
cela n'ira nulle part parce que rien ne
s'est produit
la présentation des arguments doit
débuter
demain et le procès pourrait se terminer
avant la fin de la semaine prochaine
quant au verdict il ne fait pas l'objet
d'un grand suspense étant donné la
majorité républicaine au sénat
le troisième procès en destitution
l'histoire américaine devrait se
conclure par l'acquittement de dans
notre chambre
et si jean françois bélanger
radio-canada washington